Speaker 1: CNN has obtained the audio of Donald
Trump in 2021 talking about classified documents
that he has.
This audio, which I'm going to play for you.
Contradicts many of Donald Trump's recent
claims during interviews about classified
documents.
It also contradicts Trump's claims that he
declassified everything while president.
Remember, this is one of the arguments.
Well, I can't possibly get in trouble for
what I did with classified documents after
leaving office because I declassified all
of it.
If that were the case, we wouldn't have Trump
on an audio recording saying these are classified
because he would have declassified them.
CNN exclusive CNN obtains the tape of Trump's
2021 conversation about classified documents.
Let's just play it.
This first aired last night on Anderson Cooper's
program.
It is extraordinary.
And at the top level, it is notable for two
reasons.
Number one, it exposes Trump's crimes.
Number two, it exposes Trump's lies.
And, of course, they are, in many cases, interwoven.
Speaker 2: Sick people.
Speaker 3: But that was your coup.
You know that.
Against you?
Speaker 2: Well, it started, right?
Speaker 3: It's like what the middle is talking
about.
Oh, you're going to try to do it.
They were trying to do that before you even
were sworn in.
That's right.
Speaker 2: Trying to overthrow your life.
Well, it was merely.
Let me see that.
I'll show you an example.
He said that I wanted to attack Iran.
Isn't it amazing?
I have a great parliamentary system.
Just came out.
This was him and he presented me.
This is off the record.
Speaker 1: Okay, So Trump first says this
is off the record.
That's not indicative of anything related
to the classification status of the documents
so far.
No issue.
Let's continue.
Speaker 2: They presented me this.
This was him.
This was the Defense Department.
And then we looked at Trump.
This was him.
This wasn't done by me.
This was saying all sorts of stuff.
It's pages long and all this.
Speaker 3: And, you know.
Speaker 2: I just fell.
Isn't that amazing?
Just totally wins my case, you know, except
it is highly confidential.
This is secret information.
This your attack?
Speaker 3: And Hillary would print that out
all the time.
Speaker 2: He said she sent it to Anthony
Weiner for perjury.
By the way, is that incredible?
Yeah, I was just saying, because we were talking
about and he said he wanted to attack Iran.
And what and he said the case for this was
done by the military.
Given to me.
I think we can that the war.
Speaker 3: Was the same now to try.
Speaker 2: To do it last year out since President
Kennedy said that.
Speaker 1: That is critical.
That is.
Speaker 4: Critical.
I can't.
Speaker 5: You know, but this is.
Speaker 3: A problem.
Speaker 2: Isn't it?
Speaker 1: Trump said.
As president, I could have declassified it.
And a staffer says, Yeah, and laughs.
And then Trump says, Now I can't, you know,
but this is still a secret.
Why would you say you could have declassified
something if you did declassify all the documents
there?
Whether Trump is now claiming he telepathically
declassified, whether Trump is claiming that
there was any default declassification, that
happens when he takes something, it doesn't
matter what mechanism he cites for declassification,
as bogus as those methods may be.
He says right here, this is still secret.
I could have declassified it, but now I can't.
Let's listen to the last few seconds.
Speaker 5: You know what?
Speaker 3: This is of a problem.
Speaker 2: Is that interesting?
It's so cool.
I mean, it's so.
Look, we're here.
I haven't.
And you probably almost didn't believe me,
but now, you know, I think it's incredible,
right?
Know, they bring some brings in jokes and.
Speaker 1: So they're Trump calls for sodas,
calls for Cokes to be brought in to sort of
celebrate the disclosure of classified documents
to people who are not cleared to do that.
So this is extraordinarily damning.
This is going to be an exhibit for sure in
the forthcoming either criminal trial of Trump
or something that will be presented by prosecutors
at possible plea negotiations to say, look
at what we have.
We've got you.
You might be better off taking a plea.
Now, not only is it abundantly clear that
this is part of the criminality, it's also
important to understand that Trump, with absolutely
no hesitation whatsoever, no qualms, no, no
reservations at all regularly lies about this
stuff.
Here is Donald Trump in that whacked out interview
last week on Fox News with Bret BAIER, which
was covered while I was away saying there
was nothing to declassify because these were
newspaper stories and articles that he had
and was showing people.
But of course, we know that that is a lie.
Here is Trump with a totally straight face,
as straight as Trump's face can be lying to
Bret BAIER.
Speaker 2: I couldn't do very close to the
document, Bret.
There was no document.
That was a massive amount of papers and everything
else talking about Iran and other things.
And it may have been held up or made up, but
that was not a document.
I didn't have a document per se.
There was nothing to declassify.
These were newspaper stories.
Magazine stories.
Speaker 1: Okay.
It is abundantly clear, folks, I mean, I know
that we on the left have a problem.
And the problem is when we see something like
this, we say, this is it, folks.
We've there is nothing that these people can
come up with now to explain this away.
And then they come up with something.
They go, no, Trump misspoke here or he misspoke
there.
Trump thought the document was classified,
but it really wasn't.
It was just Trump's mistake.
They will always have some way to try to weasel
out of it.
But we don't care about that.
What we care about is what is going to happen
in a court of law, because these are now legal
proceedings.
These are legal proceedings.
Trump says to Bret Beyer, I these weren't
classified documents in that conversation.
Remember, that interview was before the audio
leaked.
The interview was pre audio leak.
Trump says, I was showing people newspaper
articles in the audio recording released by
CNN.
Trump is clearly referring to documents from
the Department of Defense.
He's not saying, look at what they wrote in
The New York Times or whatever.
He's clearly referring to government documents
and he knows that they are classified, that
he didn't declassify them as president, that
he can no longer declassify them as an ex-president,
and that it is not something that he should
be showing people.
This is evidence of exactly the criminality
with which Donald Trump has been charged.
Make sure you subscribe to the YouTube channel,
My friends.
In May, we had more than 3 million people
watch our clips but not subscribe.
If just 10% of that 3 million subscribers
right now, we will get to the $2 million,
assumedly 2 million subscriber line on YouTube
very, very strongly and quickly.
We'll take a quick break and be
right back.